Why do we Get Ice Cream Headaches
If you’ve ever found yourself wondering
what causes ice cream headaches, well wonder
no more.
While many theories on what exactly causes
ice cream headaches or “brain freezes”
have existed for some time, it has only been
very recently that it was discovered exactly
what is going on here.
It turns out, ice cream headaches are a result
of a rapid change in the size of blood vessels
as a response to an extreme shift in temperature
in the roof of the mouth, particularly the
back of the roof of the mouth.
Specifically, what is happening here is that
when you stick something extremely cold in
your mouth and eat it quickly, such as drinking
an ice cold beverage or eating ice cream rapidly,
it rapidly cools the palate of your mouth.
Why this is significant is that there is a
nerve center located just above the back of
the roof of your mouth.
This nerve center includes nerve clusters
that send signals to the brain about changes
in body temperature.
When these nerve clusters are rapidly cooled
by what you are consuming, they are over stimulated
and send the message to the brain that the
body just lost a severe amount of heat.
This ends up resulting in the rapid contraction
of blood vessels in your head.
Shortly thereafter, the temperature at the
palate of your mouth goes back to normal and
the nerve centers signal everything is fine
and the blood vessels end up rapidly dilating.
This all can happen in a matter of a few seconds,
but the end result of this rapid contraction
and dilation of blood vessels is an extreme,
sharp pain, often in your temples, forehead,
or sometimes even in your face itself.
This ends up creating a very similar pulsing
sensation that many people experience when
they get true migraine headaches.
Migraine headaches can even be induced by
cold temperatures in some people, leading
some researches to believe there is a close
connection between what is happening during
certain types of migraine headaches and what
is happening during an ice-cream headache.
Bonus Facts:
• The scientific name for an ice cream headache
is “sphenopalatine ganglioneuralgia”.
This basically just means “nerve pain of
the sphenopalatine ganglion”.
• Not that most ice-cream headaches last
very long, typically at most 10-30 seconds
(though there have been documented instances
of these headaches lasting as much as five
minutes), but if you want to have an ice cream
headache go away a little bit faster, most
doctors suggest simply pressing your tongue
against the roof of your mouth.
This will help heat up the palate a little
faster than it would have otherwise, which
will reduce the time needed for the ice cream
headache to go away.
Alternatively, you can just consume the cold
item much slower to prevent the ice cream
headache completely.
This gives the palate a chance to keep its
temperature regulated enough that the nerve
center above it doesn’t overreact to what
it’s sensing.
• While most people at one point or another
in their lives has experienced an ice cream
headache, these headaches are only somewhat
common in about 1/3 of humans.
• The oldest documented form of something
resembling ice cream being served is from
200 BC in China.
Here they served a frozen mix of milk and
rice.
Yet another early frozen treat reference was
from Rome around the year 50 when the Emperor
Nero would have ice crushed and mixed with
fruit toppings.
The first actual ice cream references, in
terms of something closely resembling modern
day ice cream, comes from a recipe in an 18th
century publication called Mrs. Mary Eales’s
Receipts in London.
• One of the major developments in spurring
the popularity of ice cream was the development
of soft serve ice cream in the 20th century.
This method of making ice cream was developed
by a team of chemists in Britain, whose membership
included Margaret Thatcher.
They found a way to double the amount of air
per unit volume in ice cream.
This, in turn, made the ice cream cheaper
to make (less ingredients, more air), and
made it possible to have a relatively simple
machine make it to order from a spigot.